they're trying to put the internet back
in the box I'm trying to make d-roc the
most famous I turn it into a [ __ ]
verb and now you've got your perspective
[Music]
one thing to think about on that is how
I think about micro and macro right so
to me what I love is like I hate the
middle right I'd rather I'd rather sell
a $9 nine cent soda right just like
that's what the Internet's actually
doing to our society do not be in the
middle being the super duper premium or
be in the like high but right so that's
how I think about leadership like what I
like about this media play and what I do
is it's super macro like all my
employees at scale could know quite
about about me I can bring a lot of
value like there's unlimited content 19
meaningful pieces of content a day you
know you could and I'm unbelievably back
to the luxury I have of being an
entrepreneur super transparent but then
like today I had like 16 one-on-one
meetings already like and to me it's
like don't do the middle like make
content at scale internally like at
scale like the struggles you went
through that I mean you know and it's
always Association whether it's like
what happens when you start a family as
an executive like you know I based on
knowing enough about big companies I
would be absurd about year two and three
because that is the decision point for
seven years or two points and that's the
vulnerability you don't get those
returns if they don't stay for seven
years and then micro like for you to
like I couldn't couldn't push senior
players that matter more on one on one
or one on seven random breakfast drinks
dinners it just matters and at this
level at this size of a company that
you're so damn busy the opportunity to
go have drinks with four gals that look
like you that are near to is almost
never and so like you know I mean a lot
of the screw knee I take from my own
senior executives is doing that kind of
work but I just don't think they
understand the grave at the
what I call gray value
[Music]
so a lot of money Millennials nowadays
and everybody running around the world
or using Instagram so what do you think
are the best attributes of it and what
are some of the words the best
attributes are that it's where the
attention is and the media product on it
is disproportionally inexpensive so
that's to me I'm just very simple it's
it's is the is the attention properly
priced overpriced or under prices so for
me as a marketer and a businessman the
best part about it is it's
disproportionately under priced like
uncomfortably like I'm looking at my
taxes to figure out how I can spend more
money on Instagram ads for anything I
care about whether that's selling
sneakers or wine or getting my content
seen what's worse about it is it's so
popular it becomes the mirror of human
shortcomings social media hasn't changed
us it's exposed to us so everybody wants
to blame social media social media
didn't make you the PR agent of yourself
you've always been you just used to do
that at work or at the coffee shop or at
the PTA meeting so I don't think there's
a worse you know other than what I know
people think is the worst part about it
but it has nothing to do with Instagram
it has to do with 70 years of prosperity
that's what's happening in America like
we're able to worry about dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi hello yeah how are you guys good
we're hoping to like smart build a
career oriented labor model have you
thought about building their brands even
though that creates a vulnerability for
you oh we've thought a lot about that
can I give you a huge piece of advice
yeah you should disproportionally try to
make them famous so we talk a lot about
how there are movies first you should
disproportionally try to make them
famous the number one mistakes that all
these companies are making right now in
exercise and everything else is they're
scared to let them build their brands
because then they have leverage and then
they leave the number of course not and
more importantly if you're known for
building brands they'll all come to you
you'll have a pipeline greater than the
people that leave like you should almost
literally build an internal agency of
personal brands for these people it will
become a singular point of leverage for
you and your industry I really really
can't stress it enough
the second you with 59 goddamn Instagram
followers but with press cuz you've
launched show post 3 this is Karen
here's her story we love her every other
industry professional looks at them be
like my place we'll never do that yeah
and listen a bunch will leave a do it
personally I'm just telling you that's
firm not as much in the net result it's
the number one mistake that every single
professional service provider kind of
like companies making right out there
trying to put the internet back in the
box
I'm trying to make the rock the most
because I turn it into a [ __ ]
and now
[Music]